I've got this friend who drives a car ...
the only way to describe it is it's just
a piece of crap. It's just the worst car
on the planet. I mean I don't know and
here's the problem; is the guy actually
has money. Like a lot of money but he's
just become a freak about this car.
Like he'll spend money on other stuff he
takes his family on vacation and they've
got a nice house, but he's like it's like
this car is some kind of a reverse
status symbol for this guy. And you know
and you know, Lord willing most people
more people would be like that rather
than driving around in cars you can't
afford with car payments to impress
people at a stop light you'll never meet. A
lot of you spend a lot of money to
impress people you will never meet with
your car and I've got some nice cars I
like cars, I'm a car boy, there's no
question about that, but man when we were
broke we were driving .. well to start with, I
was driving a Jaguar and then I went
broke and I sold it the day before they
took it, so that they didn't take it to
avoid the repossession; the proper thing
to do to try to pay my bills of course I
didn't pay the whole bill, I had to sign
a note for the difference. And as part of
the bankruptcy, it was a disaster
and so we're down to one car. So a friend
of mine loaned me a car like my buddy
has. He loaned me a .. true story, a 1978
Cadillac, with 478 thousand actual miles on it.
The predominant color on this puppy was
bondo. It had a vinyl roof and when you
drove it, the vinyl roof was broken loose
so it filled up with air like a
parachute on top. So I'm driving bondo
buggy with a parachute on top. I drove
that car for 10 years one three-month
period, but I saved some money buddy,
because I wanted out of that car, I want
to take my friend his blessing back. But
it rolled, it started; most the time it
started, and most the time it rolled. And it
got me there. It was really, really
embarrassing; humiliating is a better
word. To drive that car to our church,
because that the church we were going to
people didn't have cars, like they had
nice cars. A lot of them were in debt and
had car payments, I knew that, but I'm
still sitting there driving bondo buggy
with a parachute on top up to the church.
I park it and the top settles, like ... you
know it drops down.  That seems like 20
minutes ago. It was almost 30 years ago.
I drove like no one else so that later I
could drive like no one else, so now I've
got nice cars again, and of course this time
they're a very small percentage of our
net worth;  a very small percentage of our
net worth. And of course I paid cash for
them and they just in other words,
they're small enough percentage of a
world they don't matter. Well my buddy's
got money and were he to buy at least
one decent car it would be a small
percentage,  a very small percentage of his
world .  He's probably worth 20 million
dollars, I don't know, but something like
that, and he's driving this $200 car and
it's ticking me off , 'cause I'm like
dude, you are not modeling success here.
You know this is not anything to be
proud of; you drive a 200 dollar car so
that you never have to drive a 200 dollar
car again. That's the only reason you
drive a 200 dollar car.  Not because it's
a badge of honor, it's not something to
be proud of son. And I can't get through
to him, so I don't know what I'm going to
do with him. But he's the reverse of most
Americans. Most Americans the average car
payment in America is 386 dollars over
84 months right now. Driving a car you
can't afford, not even close to being
able to afford it, and then scratching
your head wondering why your kids
college fund didn't fund. Well you're
driving it!!  You're driving the college
fund that's why!  I mean I get why my
friend has become such a freak about his
car. I get why he's thinking that way.
Because so many other people, most other
people, are the opposite end of the
spectrum. I mean he's a little overboard
and a little bit freaky about this old
beat-up car, but most you are just stupid.
I mean just most of America is just
straight up car stupid!  You fleece your
car, acting like that you when you rented
your car, you did a good deal.  Give me a
break!  And the stupid thing loses 60 to
70 percent of its value when you buy a
new one in the first four years that you
drive it. So you turn thirty thousand
dollars into eleven thousand dollars and then
scratch your head and wonder why you
can't get ahead financially. What if all
your investments; what if all your IRAs,
you put money in a mutual fund, every
time you did it you turn thirty thousand
into eleven? Well everyone knows that's a
formula for not getting rich. Hello!  This
is not hard to think about people! It's
the largest thing we buy that goes down
in value. That's why my friend's become a
freak about it. He's like I don't want to put
money and something goes down in value.
I'm like yeah, but you're embarrassing me
and everybody else that knows you. Buy a
car son.  Even if you only spend ten grand,
I mean it's what one one-one hundredth
of a percent of his net worth or
something?  But the rest of you are driving .. you
know you're making thirty thousand
dollars a year, you're driving a seventeen
thousand dollar car.  Well,  that that's
just nuts!!
It's just nuts!  You got a household
income of 60,000 bucks, and mama gets a
$32,000 SUV. Somebody ought to smack you!
That's just nuts! You do not have the
financial margin to lose thirty thousand
bucks. To lose ten thousand bucks. To lose
twelve thousand bucks. If you've got
enough money that you can throw twelve
thousand dollars off the edge of a
bridge, and it not damage you, then you
can afford to drive a car that expensive.
But this idea that you can just ..'well I can
afford it', what most people mean when
they say that is they think they can pay
the payment if they keep their job. Let
me help you with a new definition of I
can afford it. I wrote a check and paid
for it; that's the definition of I can
afford it. If you can't pay for it, in
cash, in total, on the spot cash on the
barrelhead, you can't afford it. Whatever
it is; your car, your clothes, your
groceries. Some of you are charging
groceries. Huh. Talk about financing a
depreciating
asset. Wow. We've lost our minds in this
culture guys, we really have. And all of
it is because people have been sold
stuff and sold stuff and sold stuff, and
they've got this entitlement thing, and
they say, you know I meet 42 year old men
who say stuff like I deserve a nice
truck because I work hard. You don't
deserve anything, you little child!
'Cause  you work hard. What do you think, that
makes you pregnant?  Nobody else is  ..
nobody else is out here not working hard.
Well some of them aren't, but I mean everybody
works hard deserves to go deeply in debt
by truck that can't afford is that what
you're saying?  That's your philosophy of
life?
How stupid and backward is this? So
here's an idea, pay cash for your cars,
and don't let your cars and boats be
more than half your take-home pay and
then that's an indication that you're
not got too much invested in things that
are going down in value.
I'm not against cars. I'm not against car
dealers. I'm against people doing stupid
stuff with cars that cause them to be
broke and that includes car payments and
leasing fleecing your stupid car. There
we go. This is the Dave Ramsey Show.